welcome everyone to our first dc
thursday of 2021.
um great to have everyone here i know
some of us geeks might be
glued to the price of bitcoin watching
it approach
40 000 40 000 usd but um thanks for
tearing yourself away from your wallets
long enough to join us for
dc thursday um we have a great
lineup of shows and interviews
for you this year and i'll be continuing
to
to guide you through that process um
anna and i here have been
researching and pulling together lists
of folks that we want to join the
program and last year was such a great
success
but we're all sort of close to our
screens due to the pandemic that
we've learned a bunch and and have a
great line of programs for you for this
year as well
so um i just want to thank everyone for
joining
and uh mention just a couple
of announcements before we start
you recall that we do support live
questions in the chat so you can feel
free to
drop your questions in the chat for our
guests and
we'll be happy to try to get to them
time permitting
and also if you want to be notified of
the other great dc thursday shows that
we have lined up for this year you can
just hit the subscribe button on youtube
um and also click the the bell button
which is the notification button in case
you want to get notified on your mobile
device or
on your on your desktop so today
i'm really excited to introduce td das
td is here from databricks
and td has been um
he has a really interesting history a
10-year
veteran of the data world and
um hails from uc berkeley grad school
where he started to work on the spark
project very early with mate
who's the co-one of the co-founders of
databricks so td has been working in the
spark ecosystem for 10 years
he's contributed heavily to spark as a
pmc
as a core contributor he's also taken
the lead on spark streaming
that sort of came down through the ages
so td
um welcome thank you very much for
having me here it's a pleasure to be on
this
exciting channel yeah awesome to have
you um and i just wanted to sort of
dive in and chat with you about some of
your early career experience because
um as i mentioned you have sort of a a
really amazing past and seeing
the the birth and the evolution of spark
and so i wondered if you could share
with us a little bit about how you got
into
this world and what the start of your
career looked like
all right all right so yes as
you correctly gave an introduction that
it's been 10 years i've been working in
the spark world so
that 10-year journey started with me
joining
the amp lab in uc berkeley where spark
all these projects started
i joined as a grad student uh
my one of my first projects was to help
out mate who wrote spark was writing
spark at that point of time help out
him building that project testing it out
doing running benchmarks
typical grad school stuff uh and so
that's when it started in 2011 at 321
right now
uh then after the spark project mate and
i together started uh brainstorming
further to take
uh to extend it for not just batch data
but streaming data so that's where
that's where the idea of spot streaming
came into the picture that roughly
happened at the same time when
uh for those of you who remember apache
storm was getting popular as the first
open source distribution processing
system and we saw that it was very
limited
in very obvious ways in terms of fault
trials etc so we thought why not take
uh the spark engine and push it to
uh in a new direction to make it as fast
as possible so that we can run stream
processing jobs on it that led to spark
streaming
a single engine that can do both batch
and stream processing
and a consistent set of apis between
batch and streaming
the rdds and d streams for those who
have played with sponsoring
the old class park streaming before um
consistent apis because there's a
similar semantics
uh between them uh does making it makes
the user the developer's life much
easier
uh so that went on for next
three four years till around 2014 2000
uh and within that time frame we saw
spark streaming gain
a lot of popularity becoming almost the
de facto standard of stream processing
uh
and uh but then we realized working with
hundreds and thousands of developers we
realized the shortcomings of smart
streaming as well like we have to solve
the next level of problems
and in the same time
rust who uh started the spark sql
project was building
the spark sql engine so the natural next
step was
to kind of take the best of both worlds
take this
much more hyper optimized sequel engine
and build a streaming engine on top of
that to take advantage of
the entire sequel optimizer and stuff
and so that led to the the
next iteration of stream processing
engine the structure streaming engine
since 2015 um
and and that went down and and that now
structure streaming has become a pretty
much of a standard in stream processing
uh so that went until 2018 to the
19. so somewhere around 2018 the same
team that built
in database that built structure
streaming um
work realized after working with again
developers
customers etc that solving
giving nice apis um
to make it easier to write your stream
processing
workload solves only half of the data
engineers problems
because ultimately data engineer wants
to solve the end-to-end problem of
writing end-to-end pipelines that takes
raw data and
produces data insights for that
processing only one hour with the second
half of it is storage of data in
uh structured ways such that
it can deficient to retrieve the data
when needed
and you get all sorts of uh
data quality guarantees like transaction
guarantees asset properties etc
typically for last many decades
databases have been the gold standard
for it because it gave all those uh
data quality guarantees out of the box
but data lakes
uh on hadoop ecosystem etc didn't have
a lot of those properties and that's
where we realized that we need to solve
that problem as well in order to make
the the end-to-end problem of building
data pipelines
easier holistically easier um
so we started building this newer
project our newest project called delta
lake since 2018
which is basically uh
a lot more structured but scalable
storage format similar to parquet
but imagine all sorts of asset
transaction guarantees on top of it
with while maintaining a full history of
all the transactions that happened
and you be being able to travel back in
time to query previous versions of the
data so all of those
nice things that some of which you
expect out of a database
uh bringing all of that in into this
data lake world so delta lake is our
current
most active project right now built by
the same team that has been working on
spark for last many many years
got it well that's um that's quite a
rundown of of projects across the decade
um let's dive into the streaming stuff a
little bit first
um what what did you discover was um
sort of the main use case for the
streaming the early streaming systems
that you were working on so
the main use cases where
uh so the earliest ones um
had the the earliest ones as well as
still continues to be the major use case
is essentially etl you have lots of data
coming in in the form of logs or sensor
data and stuff
and you want to be able to collect the
data and store it for post processing
and and you need a system that
scales to large volumes of
logs like gigabytes of data coming in
per day per hour
so be so on like if you dial back to the
late 2010 uh late 2000s where hadoop map
reduce
just came in that solved the the hadoop
ecosystem the hdfs with mapreduce solved
the problem
of storing very large volumes of data
and processing on very large volumes of
data
in a scalable manner what it did not yet
solve
was doing it in as close to real time in
a streaming fashion as possible
that's where that led to the the advent
of
apache storm back then because that was
the first system that
could consume large volumes of
data from other engine other streaming
sources like kafka or flume um
there were a few others rabbit mq etc
in a scalable manner and storing it on
let's say hdfs or something
um in us in real time and in a scalable
manner
and so so that the data stored in hdfs
can be queried later for india so that
was
the one of the most important use cases
right from the beginning and still
continues to be
um and storm came out of twitter right
um so that was sort of
like indicative of the twitter style
data flow which is obviously you know
why they had to
come up with storm in the first place
exactly exactly exactly
uh yeah twitter being twitter they were
obviously one of the most real-time
products out there and so they
definitely needed the
most real time and scalable engine at
the back so that's why they came up with
this
and stuff which was the start of the
whole big data stream prevention
but where uh
and we saw the rise of that but where it
storm did not initially do very well
was to provide end-to-end guarantees
that if you have
uh one record coming in from let's say
kafka
or from whatever source you're reading
from you want that record to be
exact present in the final on hdfs
exactly once not duplicated not missing
data
uh it didn't do didn't do very well in
providing those guarantees uh
because the way it was architected first
iteration the
this is true for any tool which is the
first
iteration of an attempt to do something
really challenging
and that's where that gave us the
motivation that we can do
better and we can do it in an engine
such that it solves a whole lot more
problem because earlier people used to
uh have two different stacks one
the map reduce stack for batch
processing and uh
and the storm stack was team progressing
with different code and
causing inconsistencies between the
produce results and stuff
uh we wanted to solve that problem as
well in in at one go so that's
what led to spark streaming so that was
a large that was a large design
requirement of start of spark streaming
is that it would support the
exactly one semantics exactly exactly
uh it's uh and so
so if going back to your original
question etl
was one of the large use cases the other
large use case was
real-time alerting um which again
storm being providing a very low latency
millisecond
latency was very good at when designing
smart streaming we
kind of realized that a batch processing
engine even if we push it
further down cannot
further into like optimize for that it's
really hard for it to
provide uh realistic level latency so
that's another conscious choice we've
made
that we we kind of conjectured that for
a
vast majority of stream processing
engines be it atl beat alerting
and everything in between second scale
latencies
was good enough for like 1995 percent of
the use cases that's what our conjecture
hypothesis was
and we we went ahead and built spot
streaming with
that limitation that maybe we'll get to
uh second skill latencies like half a
second and stuff but not lower than that
but that is okay the other benefits in
terms of usability in terms of
uh guarantees etc that we provide
is going to be much much more useful for
the broadest class of uh streaming
problems so achieving
and and so i guess that's the
um that's the design decision that led
to the micro batch
um sort of concept is that right exactly
exactly
exactly and we we thought this will be
good enough for most of thing and
looking back the hypothesis that we made
is still
true eight nine years later since we
made that hypothesis so yeah some some
decisions
were right back then and because we are
still doing micro batch architecture
and uh it's like it's still i can claim
that
90 high 90s i couldn't put an exact
number
90 to 95 95 or even higher amount
percentage of workloads that we see in
stream processing
is basically second scale latency is
good enough
and do any of the other common
frameworks support or
sort of um are they built on micro batch
technology or is spark streaming the
main one or the only one
so at this point spark streaming and the
subsequent structure streaming
uh are pretty much the only one built on
in in a micro batch format uh
because it's it's one of the only
engines out there
which really pushes has
has this exact same engine at like the
underlying nuts and bolts
running both batch press bad jobs as
well as streaming jobs in the exact
same job task etc format
which makes it easier to
deploy and manage as well that you can
uh if you have tuned the your
setup to work for batch workloads you
don't need any additional tuning to work
for
streaming workloads so that's only some
one of the only engines that still does
that so yes we are
the only ones with micro batch again
with the known limitation
but does it really limit everyone
leave it anyone if 99 of your use cases
don't care about the limitation
got it yeah i i definitely understand
the argument
um and then so then fast forwarding on
to to spark to structured streaming so
what was the main
sort of design goal of improvement
future improvement of structured
streaming
yes yes so um
so smart streaming after developing it
for three four
years and working with developers we
realized
the two main flaws of the spark
streaming's
api design one
was that the way spark streaming
defined uh micro micro batches
is based on when the
data arrives in spark streaming so it
basically is to cut off
data based on the arrival time so if
you're doing
sort of windowed aggregations that give
give me the average
of data based on when the data was
generated which is called the event
time basically okay let's take an
example you have data coming in from a
sensor
and you want to calculate the per
hour or per minute average uh
sensor value so you when you say per
hour you want you care about not
when the the hour being defined not on
the time stem when the data arrived
into the processing engine but you care
about the timestamp
when the data was generated in the
sensor
so that sort of that event time and
windows or windowed aggregates based on
event time
was very hard to do in spark streaming
because pakistani minor did not have the
first class concept
of event time and incorporating event
time
in the doing
incorporating event time in doing
aggregations
was very hard in the smart streaming's d
stream api
that was problem one problem two
is that d stream the api itself
while the operations like the map reduce
count those filters those operations
were exactly same
as the operations in the sparks
rdd which is the batch side of things if
the classes were still different so the
user would have to do
some rewriting of the code to run the
same business logic
between batch and stream which is
which was a game changer coming from
mapreduce and storm
a very minor rewrite compared to
rewriting map reduced to storm
but uh still not the best
so we want so that like we wanted to
build something
that takes the
that allows the developer to write one
code
and then let the engine figure out that
uh
based on the intent of the user run it
in one shot on a finite amount of batch
data
or run it continuously on continuously
arriving streaming data
but the code should be exactly the same
no need to rewrite anything
and that's those are the two main
motivations that
led to structure streaming uh
that well those were the drawbacks of dc
in the electrostructure streaming
the other motivations of building
structuring was to take advantage
of the sql engine underneath so
the sql engine the new batch data frame
api is that essentially
is a programmatic mirror api of sql
and which all boils down the same
logical plant and the cat sparks
catalyst optimizer
comes in to optimize it and spark sql
engine runs it on
with rdds taking advantage of all of
that
all the performance benefits that comes
from all that optimization steps and
stuff
take advantage of that in us in to do
stream processing as well
so that was like a non d stream but a
main
motivation to build structure streaming
on top of the sql engine and what we get
what we got there for free
is uh you can write sql you can
reuse the same data frame api to write
your business
logic and then based on a few
additional flag outside the business
logic you can
ask spark to either run it on a batch of
data or
run it continuously in structure
streaming with
continuously arriving data so that
achieves the
best of both worlds got it
so so these were all the steps in sort
of the evolution
of the data processing um
strategy of the databricks products and
being able to sort of seamlessly embrace
both batch
and stream um was a key design decision
that you made across across all of these
enhancements so so then i guess the next
step as you mentioned
i think in in your earlier comments was
um it's not only about being able to
process the data in an efficient way
that hopefully reuses business logic
across even streaming and batch which
you were able to do
but the next stage is then what about
the storage of the data so
so did the concept like was the concept
of a data warehouse sort of
a clear and present thing in databricks
um at this time and how did you
how did you sort of sort through that
absolutely
very good question so basically for the
last
one and a half decade the if you think
about how
data storage has evolved the weight
so before for the last more than half a
century
our databases and data warehouses built
on databases has been the gold standard
uh databases gave all the data quality
transaction guarantees all of those
properties out of the box
what so it was great at that but what it
was
not particularly great at or it was
not cost effective to do uh
was to scale out and have a
very large volumes of data like
gigabytes terabytes
petabytes retail was not built for that
and that is what led to the development
of the whole
uh the original google map reduce and
from that hadoop
reduce hadoop file system and all of
that as a completely
rethinking of the entire architecture
where the scalability is prioritized
over data quality
so and that's what led to the lake house
the the the sorry the the data lake
architecture
where well that's why
it's uh definitely what led to object
storage and s3 like structures in the
cloud
first of all right which are exactly
very simplistic
but um but massively horizontally
scalable exactly and so and and so i'm
sorry
i cut you off but you were you were
getting to the the the part about the
the lake house so yeah but it
before you get to that it's important to
understand the pros and cons of these
two
alternate realities is one is there were
data warehouses on databases which were
good at transactional guarantees but not
scalability and data lake was exactly
the opposite was
built for scalability but did not
provide transactional
guarantees or any kind of data quality
checks out of the
box so for the last uh bet more than a
decade
companies who deal with large volumes of
data
has had to maintain these two
alternate stacks uh for
very high profile data which needs those
guarantees etc
you they maintain a data warehouse and
databases for
larger volumes of data which doesn't
which is mostly append only because
and doesn't need that much guarantees or
doesn't need to be
that much reprocessing guarantees uh
they maintain a data lake uh
over the last two three years we are
seeing a convergence of this exactly
mimicking in the same way spark and
spark streaming led to a convergence of
the
processing stack uh between batch and
streaming being
merged together into spark streaming
streaming we are seeing the similar
pattern
between these two storage stacks data
lakes and data warehouses
and delta lake is
one of the tools which is kind of
leading the charge of
being able to combine that because delta
lake
is built on the same principles as
data lake as in fully scalable storage
rights and everything but takes
uh some of the fundamental core
principles of databases like maintaining
a transaction log and which is
atomically updated
on every operation takes that and
applies it on the principles it kind of
combines the best of both worlds
in an attempt to get you the scalability
of data lakes
and the transaction guarantees of data
bases and data warehouses
the lake the lake house that's the new
architecture
we have been proposing and driving with
delta lake being the vehicle of that
uh is the lake house architecture that
you do not need two different stacks you
can build one stack on top of
all the data lake tools like
s3 and all of these infrastructure that
you are maintaining for data lake
but you can directly leverage all that
scalable infrastructure
uh to do all the computation that you
have been traditionally doing
on data warehouses move it over to data
it does
end to end simplifying your data storage
architecture as well
and and and as i said that is
like the second half of the
your ultimate data engineers or data
scientists ultimate goal to
derive insights from the raw data so
over the last decade if we have spent
better part of it
simplifying the first half make
processing easier
scalable efficient whatever uh now we
are
working to make the second half easier
by
completely uh changing how storage
should be done yeah and uh building on
top of it
and that makes perfect sense um so what
about the actual storage
uh the file format does does a lake
house require
a universal file format or does the data
still sort of live in its own
disparate file formats depending on the
system
so so before delta lakes
the the common file formats that were
used for data lakes where things like
park a
orc j7 and stuff and the more structured
it is like par qrc the better the
performance you get so it was
recommended that using but the common
thing across across all of this is that
these
file formats were open file formats so
any processing engine any tool could
read it this is in
direct contrast with databases which
essentially maintain their data in a
very highly optimized but
internal format that only the databases
engine can read and
nothing else so and and that was another
principle tenet of the data lake
architecture that file formats will be
open so that any processing engine can
access the data
in parallel without relying on a single
agent to
provide the provide the data
[Music]
so in delta lake to continue with the
same trend what we do
is that we store the data underneath
in parque file format so the individual
files are
formatted by parquet but uh
to read the data you need to
you can to read the data correctly or
um you need to read the delta's
transaction log first because the
transaction log
uh maintains a
log of which are the files that need to
be
read for you to get a consistent
snapshot view of your delta lag table
so you need to read the log first which
is also stored in the same file system
therefore the log is also scalable
and the and you the log data is also
maintained using parki and json so
again the same engine
can spark can scalably
read the transaction log if the log is
large and
allow the system to scale to millions
and tens of millions of files
uh so you have to read the log first and
then only will you know
that which actual parquet data files to
read
so the summary of what it does is that
if your system if your pricing engine is
uh can understand the delta lake format
basically it knows how to read the delta
lakes transaction log
uh then you get the best of both worlds
you get the transaction guarantees
snapshot
isolation you get considerating
consistent snapshots asset guarantees
while being able to access the data
using open formats like parque and stuff
uh and on scaling and the data
completely distributed
so so this is this is a fascinating
architecture um and i guess to be able
to support
all of the acid-like guarantees um some
notion of schema
i mean at the same time this horizontal
um sort of distributed data
scale there must be a lot of tricks
involved to doing this and i guess one
of the
one of the complaints i've heard about
hootie or
iceberg or these types of systems is
that
they're quite complicated um to run and
maintain
like what's what's your answer to that
so um
so i think though ultimately our goal
with this project
is that the the developers
should not have to think about the
complicated problems we want
to make some of the problems
like easier and natural for example
one thing that we majorly do is in terms
of schema
is we have schema enforcement the way
it works is that okay think about
if you're using a parquet table it's
there is nothing blocking you from
accidentally writing
a bunch of parquet files in a particular
table directory
which are of a different schema and
format
than the rest of the data and then you
your
table is essentially corrupted because
you have data
in inconsistent formats so and the major
reason that happens is that
the tools that are writing into the
table does not
have any knowledge of what is the
existing data in it what is the schema
of the data present in it and therefore
it cannot check
what it what it's writing is valid or
not
that's where delta comes into the
picture where because it maintains
all of that metadata information in the
transaction log
before doing any right it can
successfully enforce
that is the data being written in the
correct schema or not
and then it can take it a step further
that and this is where
making things simpler for the developer
comes into picture
is that it can do automatic schema
evolution for example if you want
if you have new data coming in that has
an additional column
which is in that new schema which energy
column is perfectly consistent with
the old schema because you're just
adding a new column of data
it will identify that and automatically
evolve the schema of the table in the
metadata
that oh now the table has a new column
and that's okay
so and the user doesn't have to
like think about it how you would have
to do it in the pure sql world
in the old school database add the
column and only then you can write it
here it can be a lot more seamless
that's a great feature flip a flag
that turn on schema evolution and then
if you have a streaming pipeline that
is continuously writing data into a
delta lag table
you flip that flag uh for schema
evolution and
if your data happens to have new columns
added and stuff
it will automatically get added without
your manual intervention does making
the your the developers the data
engineers
life much easier that it doesn't require
manual intervention
but it is safe because for example if
the data comes in where
it is incorrectly changing the data type
of a column
it will block that it will fail when it
is supposed to fail because
the schema change is not correct but if
it is it will allow things
like uh new columns added etc
when uh when it is safe to do so
and these are some things that we we
made a very opinionated policies
on what schema changes are allowed and
what are not
in order to minimize downstream
confusion that is something
uh that i we believe delta has done it
better than other systems like
hoodie and iceberg it's got it
got it um great well that's uh
you know that that's a that's a super
compelling vision um
and i want to just take a question from
one of our audience
my inc who's asking can you help with
understanding the benefits that a lake
house will bring if we want to power
mlai solutions so how does the lake
house sort of
apply to the machine learning world
absolutely great question mayank so it i
mean that is
ml and ei is one of the biggest
motivation for unifying these two data
lake and
data warehouse worlds into lake house
because
think about what used to be what it used
to be earlier so
data that was locked in the database
data warehouse
ml systems could not read the data
because only databases
could read that data so the way that
people used to integrate data warehouses
and
is to explicitly export the data from
the databases format to an external
format like package.json
uh and uh only then uh
would it uh give me a media i'm getting
a call for
let me hand this
sorry about this
okay thank you uh
so where was i so yeah so people would
have to export the data from the
database
into an external format like park a json
csv whatever
and only then the ml systems could read
it which is
extremely time consuming resource
consuming process to export it every
time
because ml systems could not directly
read the underlying data in databases
with data lakes and lake house you can
have this
or you can have the best of both worlds
you can have a
very fast efficient sql query engine
just like databases accessing the data
but ml systems can also directly access
the data without the need to export and
stuff
because that has been filed because of
the open file formats
exactly because and that's the point of
lake house that you
can have one single infrastructure
that drives and allows
any processing needs any analytics needs
to be built on top of it be it sql for b
analysts or be it
mlai for data scientists all in the same
way in an efficient manner
so in in practicality are you seeing
that this
this vision is actually being sort of
embraced by the market
our people sort you know were before
they probably had a
warehouse um you know and maybe a data
lake
sort of um just by default because
people were storing data in s3 and all
kinds of different places
they probably had a a time series
database maybe
um or some other kind of olap database
like they had you know all these
different data structures are you
seeing all of these converge and people
are sort of spinning down
systems that used to exist and
essentially migrating them to delta lake
the the change is it's it's still a very
nascent concept i think
as a technology not just data breaks but
we are not there yet to kind of
completely move
i think we are building that it
obviously takes
years for any technology any new uh
technology a new paradigm to mature
i think but the change is happening i
think this
in 2020 we have seen in our customer
base a lot of
use cases that were traditionally done
using uh dedicated data
bases or dedicated key value stores
uh being transitioned over to
something like that to do delta lake
to make it more cost effective and
cost effective scalable and efficient so
that change is happening but it is still
the early days but it's good to know
that there is
uh this is the trend that we are going
to see for the next two three four years
that there is going things are going to
be converging more and more
got it so what what about the immediate
product roadmap
um for delta lake what sorts of major
enhancements are you working on now
that you can share with our listeners
that they should be prepared for in the
near future
so absolutely good question i think
some of the major work that we are doing
in delta lake are
things like like pushing the boundaries
of schema evolution
and schema evolution is something that
very few systems can effectively do
and but it is as i already explained how
it can make
a developer a data engineer's life much
much easier
with making it more like much less
manual intervention
needed uh whenever your data
types or data schema changes so scheme
evolution is something that
is a very hard problem and
nobody has done it effectively in the
past so this is where basically the
cutting edge of that
of doing that and so where things that
we are
working on is pushing the boundaries of
that scheme evolution for example
uh one of the things i'm personally
working on right now
is delta uh unlike other systems
so directly supports the the merge sql
operation
uh which basically for those who are not
familiar with what
the mod sql operation is it allows you
to absurd data
so if you have data based on a key if
the data is
so imagine you have your computing
aggregates
uh based on so which is essentially key
value data right
you want to inject or
for keys for which the values don't
already exist you want to insert
those q values and for keys where the
value already exists you want to update
them so the simultaneous absurd
operation for a set of key values can be
done
using this merge operation now
delta lake is one of the first sort of
scalable systems that
supports the mod sql operation directly
and
and schema evolution on top of merge
is one of the most cutting-edge things
we have
done and we're still continuing to work
on it and that is something no one has
even come closely
so traditional database some of the
traditional databases do support merge
operation
in fact advanced syntax uh
of mods operation but nobody supports
schema evolution on top of mod like
while you're upsetting
you can evolve the schema so these are
the kind of really cutting edge stuff we
are working on
right now and we'll continue to push the
boundaries for the next few years
great well we have another question uh
from rick
rick is asking how is spark trying to re
to smoothen the reuse of algorithms
i.e jax or pytorch in a lake house
environment
that's a good question and it's
complicated one so
let me kind of elevate that question
into the general problem that data
scientists face
is that they want to get the best
insights or to build the best machine
learning models from their data
so uh and for that
the the ml world has realized
uh that uh
that there is always that no no single
tool can provide the best machine
learning model in all situations so
they for different problems they need to
build
different machine learning uh
they need two different machine learning
tools to get their best
machine learning models so that means
that
there is a need for a platform
that can uh accommodate
whatever tool that the user wants to use
as easily as possible which means uh
and now that that need translates to
uh to how the platform needs to be
architected at different levels
so at the spark level what we have been
doing over the last
few years is that may we have made
uh our some of our ml apis a lot more
non-spark friendly for example
uh we have built
these sort of we have modeled
our apis in a closer to how
scikit-learn apis look like so that
users can seamlessly transition their
code between
scikit learn and spark ml lib to make it
easier to try out both tools
then in a different approach people who
are familiar
with pandas uh the pandas data frames we
have built
uh pandas data frames uh in python
we have built uh which has a different
set of apis than sparks data frame we
have built this new
project called pandas sorry
project for pandas called koalas which
unifies the apis and
gives a panda
equivalent api uh for spark data frames
so that just changing an import allows
you to
write take your pandas code and run it
on spark
so we on at the spark layer we are
making it
easier to integrate and
work move back and forth seamlessly
between spark and other non-smart
products
to make developers life easier so that
they can use whatever tools it is
that best suits their needs there isn't
one tool that satisfies everything
that's and one one level of what we are
doing to make things uh more you
developer friendly
at a higher level if you think in terms
of the
anti-analytics platform that databricks
provides we are making data bricks also
a lot more non-spark friendly
by incorporating all these other tools
already in our platform so that you can
have
so that users don't need to manage their
images or their developer environment
etc to
bring in pythons bring in uh tensorflow
bring all of that
explicitly our platform provides that
out of the box
uh already installed and stuff so the
moment you start
you can use our notebooks or
our platform to run uh
spark ml lib jobs as easily as uh
tensorflow jobs because the platform
provides
both so so so these are good we're
tackling at different levels
so these enhancements aren't
specifically due to the lake house
um structure of the lake house
architecture it's just sort of a general
data bricks product strategy decision
that you want
um to enable developers to run other
machine learning
algorithms sort of easily and have them
easily plug into spark execution
yes yes uh well i wouldn't say it is not
entirely tied to the lake house stuff
because
uh while we are so
i think these are parallel attempts we
while we are
making it easier to have one platform
to run both kind of jobs tensorflow
as well as spark ml lib we also need to
be able to
enable these other tools to directly
read
the delta lake format so that the
these other tools can directly
independent of spark read
the same data that is present in the
lake house
so we're definitely working
on making our uh the delta lake format
more openly accessible and
integratable into other tools
by right by by providing apis to
so that other tools can write connectors
to directory the delta format
independent of spark so that is also
something we are
working on in parallel so it's not
exactly
very intimately tight but they are not
independent either so
but ultimately we want the data to be
democratized so that
anybody can read it from any tool and
and have a single platform where you can
use anything
to read that data got it
well i wanted to switch gears a little
bit td because um you have such
great experience obviously with so many
different types of architectures and
trade-offs and tools and systems
in terms of folks out there who are
looking for career advice
i'm curious you and i have spoken
previously about sort of the difference
between
the data engineer who consumes the tools
that you're building
and then your type of work which is
maybe a little bit more tied to
distributed systems
um can you give any folks out there who
are looking to sort of deepen their
their appreciation of distributed
systems and other fundamentals that they
need to
be able to think architecturally in the
way that you're thinking like what
what would you encourage them with and
how would you encourage them to just
sort of study up and
get started in deepening their knowledge
in these areas
that's a very good question um so
yes so i am more like a system
engineer who built these the tools
who has been building the tools that the
data engineers actually use in practice
so they are the actual
heroes of their organizations who are
using the tools
to actually solve the actual problems
now
um
the current state of affairs is that
there are so many
until the world has converged in on
these different ways
right now there are so many different
tools out there that it is
often very hard to understand
or what is the right tool to use
for solving your problems and that is
the
real problem one of the real problems
that the data engineers
face on a day-to-day basis like how do
they design
and architect their data processing
pipeline using what
is the the right set of tools to solve
their problems um and
given this variety of tools it's it's i
think it's
become more crucial than before
to understand these each of these tools
with a little bit more
in depth at the architecture of these
tools behind the scenes behind the api
is to
really reason about what is the right
tool for
your purpose and so i think it is
absolutely important
more so now than five ten years ago
to for data engineers and data
practitioners
who are designing these pipelines
to spend a bit of extra time and effort
to
understand these tools a little bit more
to understand
what the the system architecture
and what each of these tools are not go
what they are good for and what they are
not good for
in order to make more educated decision
when they are designing their stuff
um and and i think that is something
that
can differentiate a good
data engineer from a great data engineer
so it's it's it is not to trivialize a
problem but it is
easier to do build
a solution using whatever
tools in a quick and dirty manner that
works
once and scales out to future
uh downstream users that that does
that that works one time for your
current needs but
it's a whole different challenge to
design it to make it future proof for
future downstream use cases
uh that needs to work using the same
pipeline and
making those kind of architectural
decisions
that are future proof requires that
in-depth understanding so
i highly recommend uh data engineers and
data practitioners to
building pipelines to spend the time and
effort to
understand these tools a bit better
and um i dug out a talk that you gave td
that i think might sort of help further
folks
deeper understanding of some of these
concepts um on designing etl pipelines
with structured streaming in delta lake
um
so we'll we'll drop that in the chat but
i think that that's a good example of
a talk that will help people go a little
bit deeper and really start to ask
um you know sort of more more prescient
questions
specifically regarding what they're
trying to accomplish and
and start to consider the architectural
trade-offs of different choices
um do you have any other advice for for
folks who are
early in their career um i guess
specifically someone in the
in the audience santosh he's asked
how do i become a data analyst but i'm a
mechanical engineer
what do you think about people sort of
transferring into data from
other engineering disciplines like have
you seen any tried and true
sort of path or type of education or
mentorship that works
so absolutely i i personally have a
number of friends who have
done that transition from uh other
non-cs
background to data analytics data
science backgrounds
i think it's it's very important uh
to uh i think the the the right way to
do it is starting
from uh
finding the right materials to
dip your toes in uh data analytics i
think
there's a lot of material out there
there are moocs and coursera
edx and stuff uh databricks
we also provide training those those
tutorials which are
those specific to the spark and delta
lag and that kind of platform
but uh there are also uh tutorials that
are geared towards
towards data uh like the
beginner data analytics there are moocs
built on
top of database platform for doing that
as well so there's a lot of material out
there
that helps that starts from absolutely
the scratch
on how to start becoming a data
analytics person
um it's it's uh
so i think the
the challenge is to put in the time and
effort
and the patience to start on that new
path
i think i've seen uh people who have
uh been impatient and not been
successful
uh in doing so but people who have been
patient to power through
uh the initial hurdle and become
very successful data science data
analysts
so uh so power through i think that's
one of the things i would like to really
encourage that it is
incredibly rewarding at the end and
people
do make that jump successfully but you
have to have the patience because
the start will be slow and that's okay
it will it is worth the time putting the
time in effort
that's right that's well said well um
we're almost out of time td
but i just wanted to ask you one parting
question and that's
in regards to the data ecosystem at
large
we saw such amazing things happen in
2020
there's many startups that are popping
up and getting um
increased amounts of funding and um you
know so many companies in the space for
doing well
i'm not just theatre bricks but
confluent and and others
um i'm just curious besides this whole
sort of delta lake
um and and lake house effect what are
the other trends that you're excited
about for 2021 and the
ecosystem at large
that's a good question um let me think
i think there i think convergence is a
common theme
convergence in terms of tools and
architectures
like for example kubernetes for example
is a one
big trend i've seen like earlier there
were 100 different
ways of managing your micro services
on you know raw bare metal or vms and
stuff
um now kubernetes has
is becoming uh like a single singular
way of
managing these uh and all the clouds
uh support some form of managed
kubernetes service
so which is a
proof that how the right
architectural decision or the right
tools designed with the right
goals in mind can lead to convergence
of different fragmented tools and so
these are the kind so convergence is i
think
that over the last decade we have seen
explosion of tools not just in data but
in terms of infrastructure and stuff
i think the next decade is going to be
more about convergence of
these tools and infrastructures yeah i
couldn't agree more there's so much
fragmentation
in the data world and i spent some time
last year writing a few articles about
that
um there's so many different tools and i
think that um you're absolutely right
that there there obviously has to be
some convergence and
it's important also as you mentioned to
really understand and be able to weigh
the underlying architectures and
trade-offs so that we start to merge
these things
in a meaningful way that's actually
future proof and that doesn't just solve
the volume of data that we have now
but solves the volume of data that we
anticipate um in five or ten years which
will
only explode through um iot and
healthcare data and all the other types
of data that are sort of coming online
with these systems that we're building
now so
yeah is just the first frontier and now
i believe that this this whole big data
movement is i'm spreading to the rest of
the world as well and so
um we really haven't seen anything yet
in terms of scale
yeah well thanks td um it was great
great to have you here
thank you very much for having me here
this was a very wonderful conversation
i appreciate it um so just a couple of
comments as we
um wrap this up please leave us comments
in the feedback forum that's in the chat
that we've posted it helps us
know what you like know what you don't
like and know what we can do better
and finally if you're an engineer who's
interested in starting a company
i personally am having office hours
every month
with engineers in our community who want
advice in getting their startups off the
ground so
um please reach out to me directly and
let me know if you're interested in
participating in one of the office hour
sessions
those are designed for the community to
support other engineers who
who want to start companies in 2021 so
remember to hit subscribe
and we will look forward to seeing you
for our next dc thursday
thanks thank you everyone and bye bye
and stay safe out there